[Music]
the day you left
for marseille i drove to the airport
i went to the gift shop and i saw this
necklace
it was gold said still water on it
i thought it'd be a little piece of home
to take with you
yes ma'am
allison came here for college and that's
where she met this girl
lina one night she found lena dead and
called the police
all they cared about was a house and
sleeping with some arab girl
i loved her i know you did but everybody
thinks that i killed her
we have exhausted every possible legal
action is the
lawyer not helping you oh doing it
myself for now
i could have what's your name
maya that's nice she's very
protective with me you seen that guy
before
no one would talk to you trust me and
not from here
it's not safe for you
she's my little girl please
[Music]
i'm not going to give up
it will be a serious mistake to commit a
crime to prove your daughter
innocent it will not get her out of
terror
let me send you in lord
please keep the watford housing
police did you ask her to lie i'm trying
to get my little girl out of jail that's
all i give a damn about
you sound very american right now good i
am
yeah and you're also a stranger here
what did you do
you just have to trust me
[Music]
you